the eve is in San Diego hey Steve how
are you the great Dave Ramsey oh my
goodness so what is your net worth Steve
out four point four right now cool and
what is that the breakdown of that
what's it invested in well most of it is
in real estate commercial buildings that
I own and I rent and one of them that I
one of them that I rent to my own
business my BMW repair business and I
have three houses one spec home that we
just finished and actually it's going to
it's going to fund tomorrow I sold it
and I was going to call you and give you
the debt-free screen but I got to tell
you the honest truth I couldn't sway I
just bought two point two more acres
down down south in San Diego and I'm
going to build 50,000 square feet of
industrial building now there you go man
your real estate got through and through
you anything besides real estate I have
about four hundred thousand in cash and
an annuity and 401k and a Ross and and I
have college funds for my grandkids
couch ends in some cash how old are you
Oh 57 cool very cool now how much of
this 4.4 million did you inherit none
zero okay and what's been your range of
income through your working lifetime uh
well now that we've you know gotten to
the point we're at now we range anywhere
from 210 to 250 but sometimes we do
better just depends why would you start
out making nothing backwards back in the
day alright and you only sell business
twenty-seven years old yeah you own a
BMW repair place and that's where some
of the money came from to get started in
the real estate that's where it all came
from okay
and you have a degree uh college of hard
knocks okay me 2.0 yeah I got you okay
alright so high school graduate alright
I school graduate a couple years of
engineering gotcha okay and I think I
know the answer to this because you've
been doing real estate and you just
bought some more real estate on debt so
your answer is going to be
a lot of it a lot of your wealth came
from using borrowed money to invest yes
sir actually you know I've been
listening to you for about I don't know
seven eight years I work on the weekends
on my side projects and I always turn
you on we your syndicated out here I
think around six o'clock on Saturday and
I've about seven hundred thousand
dollars a debt ago I was looking at my
ninety two thousand a year I wrote off
and in interest and I went you know he's
right I got to get that gone so I'm all
the way down to about six hundred
thousand now and it's going away real
fast
we've been hounding on it so you're down
from a million three in debt down the
six hundred I'm only gonna pay twenty
thousand interest this year okay okay I
did that twenty thousand if you hadn't
bought that lot you would have been
completely debt-free I would but this
projects gonna build it about out at
about eight million when I'm done and
and then I'm going to call it a day okay
all right cool are you gonna flip that
are you going to hold it no I'm gonna
sell 50 percent of it and I'm going to
hold on to 50 percent and that'll get my
rental income to about forty thousand a
month and you'll be in your clear it
probably at that point yeah okay I'll
just pay it off Oh what part has giving
played over the years in your financial
plan you know I'm I I give mainly to my
children and we do give to our church
matter of fact you've been to our Church
in San Diego to journey oh yeah and I
get back to engineering students I'm I'm
a tutor I tune fuel injection system so
I help them with their projects I give
it a whole bunch of different ways you
can't do this without giving yeah okay
what's the most expensive pair of jeans
your wife ever bought I don't do that my
wife buys that stuff and it just shows
up in my drawer you want to get $35
maybe I don't know no you're guessing
alright alright yeah love it alright and
this would be interesting for a BMW
repair guy how many brand new cars did
you buy before you or a millionaire when
I started my BMW repair I had a $200
Toyota
and not one color Center the same okay
have you ever bought a brand new car
well we well obviously in brand new BMWs
now because we do train on them but yes
we had a brand new Honda Prelude biggest
pile we ever bought I didn't regret it
but hey you know it I did it we paid it
off I've you know it's it's not smart
Vall now the next thing well sure what's
your advice to the young folks out there
listening the 25 year olds can you still
do this in America
absolutely what do you got a bet I have
more opportunity than anybody now than
we ever had listen what do they need it
what do they need to do to have four
million dollars when they're 57 they
need to learn to be a good listener
service their customer customers are
number one families number one too but
sometimes they got to take the backseat
and work hard do it right work smart oh
and by the way did you did you steal any
of this money I mean you're ripping buy
off well you know I listen to you every
Saturday and you pretty much said I'm
stealing from beyond any customers but
no I haven't no I don't know I'm just
kidding no I haven't stole them as a
matter of fact I can honestly say I will
go to my grave not owing anybody
anything deceitful stealing any money
from them everybody's taken care of I'm
the most honest guy on this planet so I
take care of everybody their money is
handled amen hey thank you for calling
in sharing your story it's inspiring
thank you sir hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]